السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان لا
اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
حي على
حي على الصلاه
حي على الفلاح
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا الله
ان الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه ونستهديه
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن سيئات
اعمالنا من يهدي الله فهو المهتد ومن يضلل
فلن تجد له وليا مرشدا واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله
وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه والتابعين اما بعد
معاشر الموحدين عباد الله فان اصدق كلام
كلام الله عز وجل
وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وشر الامور محدثاتها وان كل محدثه بدعه
وان كل بدعه ضلاله وان كل ضلاله في النار
اما بعد فيقول الله سبحانه وتعالى
يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم الذي خلقكم من
نفس واحده وخلق منها زوجها وبث منهما
رجالا كثيرا ونساء
واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به والارحام ان
الله كان عليكم رقيبا ويقول سبحانه وتعالى
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته
ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون ويقول سبحانه
وتعالى يا ايها ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا
الله وقولوا قولا سديدا
يصلح لكم اعمالكم ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم ومن
يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما اما
بعد
من المعلوم ان الابتلاءات
سنه ربانيه
فراضها سبحانه وتعالى واقتضتها حك
واقتضتها حكمه الله سبحانه وتعالى في هذه
الدار
لتكون دارا للامتحانات
في الشهوات والفقر والمرض والخوف والنقص
في الاموال والاولاد والثمرات
كما يكون العكس صحيح كما يكون الابتلاء
احيانا في كثره المال والاهل والولد
والصحه لقوله سبحانه وتعالى ونبلوكم بالشر
والخير فتنه والينا ترجعون
ونبلوكم بالخير بالشر والخير فتنه والينا
ترجعون
وقالوا قديما ثمانيه لا بد منها على
الفتاه ثمانيه لا بد منها على الفتاه ولا
بد ان تجري عليه الثمانيه سرور وهم
واجتماع وفرقه
ويسر وعسر
ثم سقم وعافيه
ومن جمله الابتلاءات
التي سنها الله سبحانه وتعالى في عباده هي
الامراض التي يبتلي الله سبحانه وتعالى
بها من شاء عباده
واعلم اخي المسلم ان الله سبحانه وتعالى
لا يقتضي شيئا كونا
ولا شرعا الا وفيه الخير والرحمه لعباده
والامراض والاسقام فوائد عظيمه لها
وحكم بالغه لو تاملها المسلم حق التامل
لادرك بيقين ان المرض احيانا يكون نعمه
ومنحه من الله ساقها سبحانه وتعالى اليه
فمن ثمرات المرض وحكمه ان يستخرج الله
سبحانه وتعالى من المريض عبوديه خالصه وهي
عبوديه الصبر وعبوديه الضراء
وهي عبوديه الصبر وهذا لا يتم الا بان
يطلب الله سبحانه وتعالى الاحوال على
العبد حتى يتبين صدق عبوديته له سبحانه
وتعالى
فالمريض
يجب عليه ان يصبر ويحتسب
لينال الاجر والثواب ويدخل في قوله سبحانه
وتعالى انما يوفى الصابر انما يوفى
الصابرون اجرهم انما يوفى الصابرون اجرهم
بغير حساب فعن صهيب الرومي رضي الله عنه
قال قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
عجبا لامر امر المؤمن عاجبا
يعجب الله يعجب النبي صلى الله وسلم عليه
من امر المؤمن عجبا لامر المؤمن ان امره
كله خير ان امره كله خير وليس ذلك لاحد
الا للمؤمن ان اصابته سراء ان اصابته سراء
شكر فكان خيرا له وان اصابته ضراء
صبر فكان خيرا له
الله سبحانه وتعالى
جمعه
سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه و
سبحانه وتالى
servانه وى
constant
‏andbulations
and testing
through desires poverty
fear lack of lack ofth lives and land
and the opposite is still true
and what i mean by this is i mean
sometimes the tribulations may also may
also manifest in the
الله
سبحانه وتالىر
ونبلوك
بالشر والخير فتنه والينا ترجعون
was
back
things
and life things have them
back mind
things man cannape
‏unionar
e
sickness and health
things every human being will
and will be tested with
while my topic today is
explicitly on one
‏I mentionck
and being
this is also the form of child and test
الله سبحانه وتالى
test serv
and before go moreil
you
الله سبحانه وتعالى
nothing good
and
have benit anddate
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى
عبوديه
الله
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالىران
[Silence]
الرومين
الله صلى الله عليه
‏affed
aff is
no matter
the cases the states you right now is
allى
‏was wondering from عجبا لامر
wonderful affire
affair is good
and this applies to none but the musl
the
this applies to none but the believer
and prop صلى الله عليه وسلمes
to
‏back الله
anders
back
and
other no
‏any
sit
as
المؤمن وصحته وماله في تقلب دائم فلا فلا
يعد المسلم مسلم مسلما حقا حتى يعد البلاء
نعمه حتى يعد البلاء نعمه ويعد الرخاء
مصيبه وذلك لان صاحب البلاء ينتظر الرخاء
وصاحب الرخاء ينتظر البلاء وليس المسلم من
اذا اشتد به المرض تمنى الموت او الهلاك
ذاك ليس بالمسلم من اشتد من اذا اشتد به
المرض
تمنى الموت او الهلاك
ومهما اشتد به المرض فلا يتمنى الموت لان
المسلم لا يزيده عمره الا خيرا فان كان
لابد فاعلا فليفعل بوصيه النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم كما ورد في الحديث عن انس بن
مالك رضي الله عنه قال قال النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم لا يتمنين
احدكم الموت
لا يتمنين احدكم الموت من ضر اصابه
فان كان لابد فاعلا فليقل اللهم احييني ما
دام ما كانت الحياه خيرا لي فليقل اللهم
احيني ما كانت الحياه خيرا لي وتوفني ما
كانت الوفاه خيرا لي
‏alless
also not wishes
when he affected by severe
some people do for themselves
الله
bec
sometimes the suff
person can be in
so no matter how in that would
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه
الله
[Silence]
وليحسن المسلم الظن بربه
سبحانه وتعالى في كل الاحوال وليتيقن ان
ما اصابه من الامراض والابتلاءات انما هي
تكفير
للخطايا ورفعه في الدرجات
عن ابي سعيد الخدري وابي هريره رضي الله
عنهما
قلا قال قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
ما يصيب المسلم من نصب التعب ولا وصب اي
المرض ولا هم ولا حزن ولا اذن ولا غم حتى
الشوكه حتى الشوكه يشاكها الا كفر الله
بها الخطايا او الا كفر الله بها خطاياه
ما يصيب المسلم من نصب ولا وصب ولا هم ولا
حزن ولا اذن ولا غم حتى الشوكه يشاكها
الا كثر الله بها خطاياه او من خطاياهم
thinking الله سبحانه وتالى
alles
[Silence]
ابي سعيد الخد
صلى الله عليه
‏illet
not even the
not even thn but
some
exerc
بارك الله لي ولكمران العظيم ونفعني
واياكم بما فيه من الايات والذكر الحكيم
اقول ما تسمعون واستغفر الله لي ولكم
فاستغفروه انه الغفور الرحيم
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب العالمين والصلاه والسلام
على المبعوث رحمه للعالمين
اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه والتابعين
وارضى عنا يا ربنا وعنهم اجمعين
الرضا بقضاء الله وخيره وشره هو من اعظم
المقامات
من اعظم مقامات الايمان ودرجات الايمان
والاحسان فاللهم ارضنا بما قسمته لنا لنكن
اسعد الناس يا رب لنكن اسعد الناس يا رب
العالمين
اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا نا محمد في
الاولين وصل وسلم على سيدنا محمد في
الاخرين وصل وسلم على سيدنا محمد في كل
وقت وحين اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد
حتى ترث الارض ومن عليها وانت خير
الوارثين اللهم عز الاسلام والمسلمين
اللهم اعز الاسلام والمسلمين
واعلي رايتي الحق والدين المبين اللهم يا
ربنا ويا مولانا ويا سميع الدعاء يا ذا
المن والعطاء
يا ذا الجلال والاكرام يا حي يا قيوم
يا بديع السماوات والارض ويا رحمن الدنيا
والاخره ورحيمهما
اللهم انا نتوجه اليك ونسالك ونرجوك يا رب
العالمين اللهم اشف مرضانا ومرضى المسلمين
اللهم اشف مرضانا ومرضى المسلمين اللهم
اشف مرضانا ومرضى المسلمين اللهم رب الناس
اذه اذهي بالباس واشفي الشافي شفاء لا
يغادر سقما يا رب العالمين. اللهم اجعل
هذا المجتمع سخاء رخاء وسائر بلاد
المسلمين بخير وعافيه وصحه وسلامه
واطمئنان. اللهم اعطنا سؤلنا اللهم اعطنا
سؤلنا اللهم اعطنا سؤلنا اللهم تجاوز عنا
السيئات وتحمل عنا التبعات. اللهم اجزي
والدينا عنا خير الجزاء. اللهم اجز
والدينا عنا خير الجزاء اللهم اجزي سيدنا
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم عنا خير ما جزيت
نبيا عن امته اللهم احينا على سنته وامتنا
على ملته واوردنا حوضه واكتب لنا شفاعته
يا رب العالمين عباد الله ان الله يامر
بالعدل والاحسان وايتاء ذي القربى وينهى
عن الفحشاء والمنكر والبغي يعذكم لعلكم
تذكرون
واخر دعوانا ان الحمد لله رب العالمين
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
حي على الصلاه
حي على الفلاح
قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا
اله الا الله
استقيموا واعتدلوا استووا
سووا الصف سدوا الخللت
لاين
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك اياك
نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
[Arabic recitation]
اذ قال لابيه وقومه ما تعبدون
قالوا نعبد اصناما فنظل لها عاكفين
قال هل يسمعونكم اذ تدعون او ينفعونكم
او يضرون
قالوا بل وجدنا اباءنا
كذلك يفعلون
قال افرايتم
ما كنتم تعبدون
انتم واباؤكم
الاقدمون
فانهم عدو لي الا رب العالمين
الذي خلقني فهو يهدين
والذي هو يطعمني ويسقين
واذا رضت فهو يشفيني والذي يميتني ثم
يحيين
والذي اطمع ان يغفر لي خطيئتي
يوم الدين
ربي رب والذي يميتني ثم يحييني
والذي اطمع ان يغفر لي خطيئتي
يوم الدين
رب هب لي حكما والحقني بالصالحين
واجعل ليسان صدق في الاخرين
واجعلني من ورثه جنه
النعيم
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
[Arabic recitation]
وبرزت الجحيم للغاوين
وقيل لهم اينما كنتم تعبدون من دون الله
هل يسمعوا هل ينصرونكم
او ينتصرون
فكبكبوا فيها هم والغاوون وجنود ابليس
اجمعون
قالوا وهم فيها يختصرون
ت الله ان كنا لفي ضلال مبين اذ
نسويكم
برب العالمين
وما اضلنا الا مجرمون
فما لنا من شافعين ولا صديق حميم
فلو لنا كره فنكون من المؤمنين
ان في ذلك لايه
وما كان اكثرهم
مؤمنين
ان
ربك لهو العزيز الرحيم
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم
4:45 5 அன் இইஷ
4:45
4:45 and pray will be at 5 পথ টা ফজর এং
সো ইনশল্লাহ
এন্ড
আ সিস্ister মரியம் மনিট
ইন্নালিল্লাহি ইলাহি
আল্লাহ
সকল সা প্রগ্ম
সার্টিং অন জুন ফই ইনশাআল্লাহ ফম এজও
ফিসকলার
সাவ
প্রফে
আকসা
ইমাম আওার
প্রমইশল্লাহ
প্রমন্
সাই ইনশল্লাহ
অনলাইন এনমেন্ট
[Arabic recitation]
and something you at make
hearing some compain about the paring
and argum or disc with the secity people
there is a reason why we have security
people it is for your security now what
tell you is something that is affected
by very ‏and to
us not the rule of law or
direction from the security people that
gives us get us trou because the
security fks are also people us so
you start offending them it becomes a
for us for the mas so is going to take a
stand on their beh
with hum
‏and sister
something
make you somebody aron pleas stand up
them are in the house of the vinity and
not be focusing on the things soy sure
this is going to go away but something
need to beind
generously on the way আসসালামু আলাইকুম
আসসালাম
السلام عليكم
الله يرضى